[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Майдан,
Галичина]
Ми в космосі. Ми так називаємося.
Космос — це синонім слова «гармонія».
[Роман Баховський,
співзасноник Cosmos prefab]
І з того починалася наша робота,
десь над тим продуктом,
яким є будинок цілий.
Ми робили ремонт самостійно
перед народженням дитини.
Це реально була жесть.
Ти стаєш експертом: електриком,
сантехніком,
ремонтником, маляром, штукатуром, матеріалознавцем,
щей рекрутером тих всіх майстрів.
І контроль якості теж за тобою лишається.
І це нереально складно
і ми почали собі так думати,
що є цілісні продукти:
машина, мобільний, ноутбук.
А будинку нема.
І десь от з того часу
ми почали собі формувати ту ідею —
створити цей продукт.
В нас багато друзів архітекторів.
Ми зібрали їх у Львові...
Анонсуємо їм це все.
Ми взагалі в архітектурі не працювали до того.
[Ярина Баховська,
співзасновниця Cosmos prefab]
Вони дуже чемно нас вислухали
і порадили, як далі працювати.
За їхніми рекомендаціями ми познайомилися з командою архітекторів Бєляєвих.
І це було стовідсоткове попадання в точку.
Вони також пластуни. І ми пластуни.
І десь вони розуміли:
якщо ти хочеш створювати
заміський будинок для відпочинку,
які емоції має людина переживати, коли вона є на природі.
Там зорі, небо — це все.
Плюс, вони створили з цього всього архітектуру.
Тут 60 квадратних метрів
загалом всієї площі.
Без терас. Є ще технічне приміщення.
Дуже важливим було продумати повністю все:
як людина тут перебуває,
як її побут тут відбувається.
Тому, що дуже класні мінімалістичні дизайни,
але коли вони закінчуються тим,
що ти не маєш де поставити побутові речі
то воно все розбивається.
Наприклад, ти ставиш, в тому мінімалізмі, посередині мітлу чи ще щось.
Воно так не має працювати.
То все має бути як в машині продумано.
Кожен сантиметр.
Наша ціль початкова була
створити будинок, в якому людина захоче
реалізовувати свої ідеї.
От ти приїжджаєш туди,
набираєшся спокою,
якийсь такий повний дзен.
І тоді в тобі зароджуються
якісь твої давні мрії,
бажання щось робити, кудись їхати,
щось перетворювати.
Будь-що.
Дуже цікаво підходили саме до розробки простору.
Ми ставили так людину.
Ми дуже романтично сказали:
«Має бути місце сили і натхнення!»
Тоді з архітектором почали думати,
як з цього попсового речення
реально зробити щось вартісне.
І зрозуміли, що не має більшого зв'язку,
ніж між природою та людиною.
Хотіли, щоб коли людина перебуває вдома,
вона максимально відчувала себе на природі.
Тут діти просто бігають
довкола будинку, вісімками бігають.
Це теж дуже класно.
Була норвезько-українська
торгово-промистолова палата.
Тут 20 чоловік розмістилось, щей з наїдками.
І дуже круто норвежці ще сказали:
«Вам, напевно то, дизайн робили в Норвегії?»
Ми такі... «Ні».
То все робила місцева команда.
Вони такі: «Вау, круто, круто!»
Потрібно дві речі.
По-перше, це відчуття безпеки.
Бо людина, це психологи довели,
що людина може розвиватись тоді,
коли вона в безпеці.
Інше — це є відчуття волі і простору.
І треба було в одному будинку
це все поєднати.
В нас було десь таке завдання.
Другий поверх...
Був такий запит.
Ми казали: «Має бути кімната господарів
і має бути місце, куди всі твої друзі
можуть приїхати переночувати.
Або де діти можуть тусуватись,
коли батьки знизу.
Це є вікно в космос.
Закриваєш люк.
І в тебе такий свій простір.
Для ночівлі. І тут дуже класно також,
що Велика ведмедиця, в деякий період року, тут закінчує ніч.
Насправді,  дуже багато речей в «Космосі»
виготовили українські бренди.
І вони дуже класні.
Ми намагались всі шафи сховати.
Дуже круто, потім діти бігають і шукають
які стіни рухаються.
Тому що, ти їх не зауважуєш,
вони тут приховані.
Щоб в очі не кидались, якісь окремі
елементи шафи.
Якщо говорити про будинок і про продукт,
енергоефективність, технології...
На нашу  думку, це є речі, які вже є за замовчуванням.
На сьогоднішній день.
З долара витраченого на будівництво
15 центів — це будівельне сміття.
Коли відбувається будівництво
і чим воно є більшим,
тим більше, відповідно, цього будівельного сміття.
Це так само десь лягло в основу того,
що ми робимо prefab будинки і так собі запланували
робити їх максимально на виробництві.
Для того, щоб правильно утилізувати відходи.
Для того, щоб оптимізовувати відходи.
І не мати тих відходів. Найважливіше.
Це дуже круто чути, реально, коли люди на одну ніч приїжджають.
Ти їх не знаєш. Ти з ними не знайомий.
Вони кажуть, що прощаються як з другом.
Ти розумієш, що простір сам працює,
сам робить те, що він має робити.
Ми таким ідемо шляхом,
що ми не робимо там бізнес заради бізнесу.
А хочемо щось трошки змінювати, доносити
і щоб люди по-іншому починали дивитись на речі.
Там головна дорога проходить.
Так виходить, що то село-глухий кут.
І люди дуже привітні, дуже класні.
Приходять після церкви в неділю.
Так заходили екскурсії.
Ми тут все показуємо. Це так круто.
Коли воно будувалося,
воно так дивно їм виглядало,
і вони не розуміли,
що це в кінці кінців буде.
Те, що тут ми без паркана.
Люди напевно теж собі дивляться, роблять висновки і задумуються:
«Як це так?»
Типу не обмотатись тут  колючим дротом.
А ми відкриті.
Тут вони можуть собі приходити  місцеві.
Подивитися, зайти.
Присісти, відпочити.
І це напевно теж
якусь довіру випрацьовує...
Воно так було. Воно все ж так було насправді.
Якщо робили огорожі, то від звірів,
які могли залізти.
Якась та відкритість була
і її просто потрібно повертати.
Повертати і як мінімум
не їхати закордон працювати.
Або важко не працювати,
щоб потім інвестувати в  паркан.
Це такий перший принцип успіху.
Якщо паркан коштує дорожче, ніж хата,
мабуть, не треба цього робити.
Cosmos був би нереальний в іншій країні.
В жодній іншій країні.
Оця  типу небезпека і жорсткі умови,
які є в Україні,
вчать тебе дуже правильно
будувати проекти.
Ризики розраховувати. Думати.
Це допомагає тобі бути сильнішим.
[автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[оператори
Олексій Панченко, Максим Завалля]
[продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[сценаристка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[режисер
Микола Носок]
[звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[монтажер
Андрій Сидорук]
[субтитрувальник
Теодор Олач]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]